-Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for watching.
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, today,
the White House announced
that President Biden
will have his first
one-on-one meeting with
Vladimir Putin on June 16th.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Yeah.
It's a nice reminder that,
after a year in quarantine,
you're gonna have to see
some people you don't like.
[ Laughter ]
I can't wait to see
how these two guys
try to out-macho each other
during the summit.
It's like, "I don't need
a bathroom break. Do you?"
[ Laughter ]
"No, in fact,
let's take off our shirts
and have a pec-flexing contest."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, this will be
their first in-person meeting
since Biden told Putin,
"I don't think you have a soul."
[ Laughter ]
It's gonna be fun
when Putin tells Biden,
"Say once more so I can use
for outgoing voicemail.
[ Laughter ]
And go now.
Say now."
The meeting will be part
of Biden's first foreign trip
as president.
He'll roll up like every other
American in Europe --
fanny pack, selfie stick,
and a love for saying,
"Hey, they have a McDonald's."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it'll be Biden's
first foreign trip as President,
and let's hope
it's just as satisfying
as his first domestic trip.
Whoop.
-Whoa!
-Oh.
Hey, oh!
[ Cymbals crash ]
-Whoa!
Like four trips in one
on that one, right there, yeah.
-Oh.
-Well, here's some good news.
As of today,
half of all adults in the U.S.
are now fully vaccinated.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Applause ]
That's right.
Half of America is vaccinated,
while the other half
uses Facebook.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right, 50%.
So basically,
one Johnson is vaccinated,
the other Johnson isn't.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Well, if people need yet another
incentive for the vaccine,
United Airlines is offering
its vaccinated customers
the chance to win
a year of free travel.
That's right.
United's first prize
is a year of free travel, while
the second prize is two years.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm good. I'm good."
Hey, I saw that
Mike and Karen Pence
just bought a new house
right outside of Indianapolis.
At first, Karen thought
the house was haunted,
but it was just Mike
stepping out of the shower.
[ Laughter ]
"You really are white, wow."
"I can see through you, yeah.
He's translucent. Unbelievable."
"It's more
of a frosted-glass look."
[ Laughter ]
Get this. In Georgia,
officials are asking residents
to stop calling 9-1-1
about cicadas.
[ Laughter ]
Stop it.
Stop calling 9-1-1
about cicadas.
Which backfired immediately
when a bunch of cicadas
robbed a 7-Eleven.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, in Texas,
a woman decided to do something
pretty crazy at the El Paso Zoo.
Watch this.
-A zoo in Texas is trying
to track down the woman
caught on video inside
the spider monkey exhibit.
She reportedly hopped a barrier
at the El Paso Zoo
so she could feed the monkeys
Hot Cheetos.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't worry.
After the incident,
the woman was quickly returned
to her own enclosure.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, people were shocked,
while the monkeys were like,
"Carl, your Uber Eats is here."